hello how are you
i'm invading your space i'm sorry
[Music]
oh no i'll wear a sweatshirt sweatpants
it's 11 30 a.m and you know what time
it is it's time to cook some ribs that's
right nothing matters and everything is
okay
that's what we're all about today hi my
name is grace helbig if you don't know
now you know your life is different now
welcome to another cooking video i'm in
my kitchen
i've cleaned only this area that you can
see gonna be a really fun time today
okay i'm a little nervous
as always because i don't have a plan
but i have lots of ambition
and an excess of ambition with no plan
could go very wrong join me on this
journey of hope possibility
and potential failure the description of
every youtube video that's ever existed
we're making a hellofresh video today
and because it's the end of the year my
last hellofresh video of 2020 i'm going
out big i'm going out in style
barbecue baby back ribs and buffalo
spiced mac and cheese
i shouldn't be allowed to be making this
in my home with my own two hands without
further ado because i feel like i'm
going to
do do myself we should just get into
this shall we let's talk about
hellofresh first if you don't know
you should know oh look there's my ring
light like an angel ghost
taunting me with its protection and its
encouragement you don't know it's
america's number one meal kit you can't
get any
higher than number one unless you want
to talk about like negative numbers and
math
and how all of that works and imaginary
numbers
we don't have time not today here are
some things about hellofresh if you
didn't know that might sway you
into person that means into possibly
getting yourself some hellofresh
hellofresh has so many different recipes
that you can choose from every week to
help you break out of your recipe rut
today is no exception and hellofresh
cuts stressful meal planning down
to just about 30 minutes it takes about
30 minutes to get all of their meals
on average onto the table sometimes 40
and sometimes 20 if you get one of their
quick and easy recipes
as always everything comes pre-portioned
all the ingredients are pre-packaged so
there's less food waste
there's less time waste there's less
just waste because we all know that all
we've been doing
other than things like this is just
wasting i wash my hair today so
hello fresh is super flexible you can
change your meal plans whenever you want
you can also
add sides you can add proteins to your
meal plan
and hello fresh is also very into giving
back in 2019
they donated 2.5 million meals to people
who needed it and this year in 2020
they're looking to go even bigger so
when you support hellofresh you're
supporting great company okay talking
points are done let's get into the
inevitable chaos
everything comes pre-packaged no eggs
correct are we we are correct i don't
know why i think i should be able to do
this but let's see if i can do it
oh you can definitely do it blindfolded
and backwards
this is a lot of stuff i have perhaps
swum into the deep end and i'm not a
very good swimmer i took
ymca swimming classes when i was younger
and when you graduate they tell you what
kind of fish you are based on your
potential of how well you swim
and on my certificate i was a guppy
i don't even know if they swim or they
just float to survive
but it was accurate get a cutting board
out that feels like something you need
if we just keep moving forward and we
don't stop to think about it none of the
anxiety thoughts can creep in
and conquer the body preheat the oven to
400 degrees so successful already now
we're gonna bring a medium pot
of salted water to a boil because we're
gonna make mac and
cheese pot's not very clean but also
you're not eating from this pot
salt in pot wash and dry all produce
yes yes yes and wow so clean thinly
slice our scallions
knife we need big knife big knife for
big race
i'm gonna try and get this done true to
time so that means i won't be talking to
you guys as much
but do we need to have small talk i feel
like small talk is just
something that we can all agree this
year isn't as important as it was
in previous years i want big talk or no
talk now in a medium bowl we need a
medium bowl
i don't want any stellar bowls i don't
want any loser bowls i want a medium
bowl you're very medium combine scallion
whites
ranch dressing and sour cream okay
basically all of our ingredients go in
here okay
sour cream come on bubba oh my god oh my
sour cream
in and a dash or two of hot sauce that
was oh three dashes wow i'm bold today
we add our coleslaw mix cabbage confetti
and then we put some salt and pepper we
mix it up
you really want to mix this up because
that cream cheese was
very much together wow coleslaw
doesn't look great now we put this in
the refrigerator until later
i like my coleslaw like i like my
friends they get ready very quickly and
then they go off by themselves until i'm
ready for them oh here we go
i got two of these was i supposed to
have two it looks like they're only
making one
making sheets so far that's what the
picture looks like i guess we'll only do
one rack of ribs huh
yeah all right oh my god just to pour
the sauce that's left in this thing
on the ribs that's a piece of plastic
that's not sauce they have been frozen i
tried to defrost them so that'll add to
the
question mark about how this end product
will be wash your hands and then we
tightly cover them with foil ooh like a
little christmas present
however fresh has done like all the work
for you look at this little christmas
present this is so cute
yeah that's pretty perfect timing these
are going to go in the oven now for 20
to 25 minutes now we have a moment to
reflect on
wow we're really doing this a moment to
breathe
because breathing is part of living a
huge important part once our water is
boiling which it is because everything
turns out is timed really well based on
these directions
we're gonna add our pasta and cook for
nine to eleven minutes
and when you squeeze nine to eleven
together you get nine one one
fun fact i'm very nervous but i also
think everything's okay so now our pasta
cooks for nine to eleven minutes now we
have nine to 11 minutes
to just be with our thoughts
oh i might have gotten barbecue sauce in
my hair just then but that's all part of
the fun
so how have you guys been has anyone
else been doing anything other than
waking up eating
at some point and then just sitting and
watching tv all night if you have let me
know because that's literally
all i've been doing every day i've been
eating
television like a pig that got led into
a chili's after hours and if any of you
have any good wrecks for document
documentaries whoa and if you
have wrecks for documentaries or
docuseries which is like my favorite
thing
please leave them below because i have
run out there's something that we can do
while we're waiting we need butter we
need a microwave safe dish do you in the
microwave play nice
a tablespoon of butter we're gonna melt
it in the microwave and then we're gonna
add some panko marco
panko and frank's red hot seasoning
to it i don't know why i feel so
scandalized by this that butter
ooh got boiled i think this is going to
go on top of the macaroni and cheese
it's like the weighted blanket for the
mac and cheese oh my god and then red
hot seasoning goes in
wow wow you're so draining and that's
why i love you did i have to put this
sour cream in something
oh you guys well we [ __ ] up i supposed
to put the sour cream
in the coleslaw i put the cream cheese
in the coleslaw
you all saw me do it you knew i was
doing something wrong egg sour cream
come on bubba
oh my god oh my god you really want to
mix this up because that cream cheese
was very much together oh it's a good
thing coleslaw's not the star of this
meal and that i have
extra cream cheese in my refrigerator
that i can use damn
it'll be okay because the good thing is
i don't think anyone really wants to eat
coleslaw
anyway they just eat it out of
obligation in a heavy meal like this
so we're doing them a favor by picking
it up and then they don't have to use it
we are the greatest chef ever sometimes
i just let my hands
meditate for a second because they've
already had some mistakes
and they really need to get focused oh
pasta's great okay
pasta get strained in the pot use for
the pasta we're gonna add our cream base
we're gonna add okay
reading the directions is fundamental to
making this meal it turns out
green based sauce holy [ __ ] this is some
cream
oh that's really thick was i supposed to
put both i'm just gonna i'm doing it now
we're just doing it gotta go for it and
fix
it along the way unless you're driving
fix your car first and then
go for it i'm just gonna eyeball the
sour cream and then we add a little bit
of the fray and then we whisk it
together for one to two minutes
look at it go i'm not frazzled you're
frozen it's smooth so now we're gonna
add our pepper jack and our cheddar
this is what we all need wow this is
like a gut
plug holy crap you will have some holy
craps with this
pasta goes back in just so you guys can
get some real asmr this is illegal this
is not right
oh okay can't wait to put the mac and
cheese into a baking dish
that was a very religious experience now
we sprinkle the panko on top of it and
then we're gonna bake it in the oven
do you guys have you done this before
this goes into the oven for five to
seven minutes until brown and crispy oh
my
i don't know what to feel like i'm doing
something that i'm not allowed to do
all right well get over it
this stuff's just gonna cook and then
it's gonna be done so
here we go
god forsaken sour cream i don't know
what i don't know what to do
do i open this i guess i do it's crazy
we made ribs oh my god we may ring oh my
god do you see this what do i do
let's cut our ribs and put them on a
plate
hello friends can you see it oh
right remember how i was so proud of you
and thought you were gonna be great but
we'll put it on the plate
oh you guys
this is how she looks on her dating
profile and then this is how she shows
up and you're like you're a nasty woman
and i don't deserve you
this is where i find out if they were
too frozen when i went to cook them or
not
wow that tastes like ribs whoa yeah yeah
it's post homecoming and we're sitting
at the chili's in the section of the
server that was just about to get cut
and we're all ordering waters and one
rib for the table really pissing her off
wow that takes me back i don't care if
this is disgusting
hello what do you got for me what sort
of terrible miracles lie
within you ma'am oh my god holy [ __ ] i
feel like i should just because i
like you've been waiting okay look
that isn't terrible it does taste a lot
like cream cheese and we didn't do it
too terribly okay before i [ __ ] pass
out all right you guys get the
hellofresh deal and you guys are
interested in getting hella fresh for
yourself
for your loved ones it could make a
great holiday gift go to hellofresh.com
use my code helbig 80 to get a total of
80
off across five boxes including free
shipping on your first box again
hellofresh.com use the code hellbig80
to get 80 off across five boxes
including free shipping on your first
box that's right right
yeah that's right oh my god okay this is
the fun thing about hellofresh is that
they throw up meals like throw up
that's the wrong phrasing have available
meals like this that might seem out of
your wheelhouse
but also a really fun thing to try lots
of possibilities you guys
breathing remember the breathing thank
you guys so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this video subscribe to the
youtube
channel
i'm trying to make some more videos
possibly in 2021 but who really knows
what 2021 will bring
any of us let me know in the comments
down below if you have any documentary
or docuseries rex for me
i need i'm all out of i can't
continue speaking sentences so i'm just
gonna go
thank you for watching i don't know
this is incredible wow wow wow
you look we'll give you a pass you've
been pardoned